AT : RANGERS WINNING A COUPLE
OF TO
DRILL
MILLER AROUND THE NET, THE PASS
OUT IN FRONT AND THEY SCORE.
TANNER PEARSON COMING STEEP GEO.
>> Joe: YEAH, PETTERSSON 13
AND THEY LOSE IT AGAIN HERE.OUT.
HE SEES KREIDER.
ALONG THE BOARDS,MYERS SHOT, SA.
GEORGIEV.
REBOUND DEFLECTS INTO THE
CORNER.
ZIBANEJAD HAS GOT IT.
FOX.ER WITH THE SAVE.
ANOTHER BEAUTY B
FORECHECK PRESSURE BY HOGLANDER.
NILS HOGLANDER, NUMBER 21 WITHT.
OFF OF THE LEFT LEG.
DOES NOT GET THROUGH TO
LUKE SCHENN TOW
JUST PUTS IT IN FRONT AND
BEAUTIFUL RANGERS, THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE T TO
HIGH ON THE SHORT SIDE.
HERE IS THE BEAUTIFUL PASS, DEF
GLOVE.
HERE IS ANO IS LAMMIKKO.ES IN D.
HERE IS SCHNEIDER TO JONES.
RIGHT B BALEXIS LAFRENIERE. DEF
THE PASS.
CLEARED OUT BY HDRYDEN HUNT.
RYAN STROME!N AND
EVENTUALLY JUST THROWING
4:10.
PETTERSSON.
GETS TO THE PUCK.
NET IS EMPTY.
AND HE PUTS VANCOUVER AND WAS